ah hello there no no don't get up put
the gun down though they don't do
anything
I'm not real how could you shoot me
there we go see isn't that much nicer
all friends face the window please
oh and smile there that's good
will you look surprised
doctor you'd be not a binge of me
haven't you I like your style
you fall down then you just get back up
shame though that's won't let me in hmm
nice couch don't get up I'll make myself
at home what are you talking about
doctor oh no I've not come here as some
sort of vengeful retribution I really
don't mind you people watching me
although I do wish you'd share them
you're very selfish taking me away from
the children like that you know I admit
I did lose my temper for a bit back
there didn't I don't worry I've came to
terms with my new audience and you do
like me a children quite often some
people would call you monsters not me
I don't judge I'm fair what are you
writing
I'm very sorry doctor but this isn't an
interview I put it in the trash now we
go everything goes in the trash
eventually you trash your precious
interviews the children trash their
little minds and even I've had to trash
some of my other gimmicks oh oh yes I've
been making little savages for quite a
while now
put down the gum I think I started off
small the idea of fire some stupid
cavemen got into their skulls children
didn't really have time for me back then
so I just moved on the skinwalker stick
though that was a good idea
children whispered about me in the dark
adults even painted me I hardly had to
do anything at all but then you had to
get clever didn't you suddenly all those
superstitions started to float away and
I had no children to help no parents to
well you'll find out soon enough and yet
there was one form that I still had left
one fun-loving character I could still
reach inside those kids heads and twist
I'm talking of course about bobble the
clown oh oh don't look so glum smile
you're on television